montigny le bretonneux guyancourt de
communes regroupées depuis 1991 au sein
du canton de montigny le bretonneux pour
un total de soixante deux mille
habitants dont moins de la moitié sont
électeurs lors du scrutin départemental
il n'est pas rare de voir les maires des
deux villes s'affrontaient ainsi en 2008
françois de ligne et maire de lui en
cours l'emportait face à michel laugier
maire de montigny le bretonneux un
scénario inverse à celui de 2015
soulignant qu'il s'agissait également de
la première élection d'un binôme michel
laugier l'emportant avec laurence
trochut cette année les élus
départementaux ne se représente pas un
scrutin inédit donc mais qui voit
s'affronter à nouveau les maires de ces
deux villes à gauche françois morton
maire de guyancourt se présente avec
claire l'avenant tandis qu'au centre
droit lorrain merckaert maire de
montigny le bretonneux se présente avec
laurence boulard and on a à la fois le
programme qui porte sur l'ensemble du
département et qui est composée de 21
points dans toutes les thématiques qui
recouvre les délégations et les missions
du département
et puis sur le canton de montigny et
guyancourt il y a plus particulièrement
aux points le département a des
compétences
ce sont des compétences que nous portons
avec nos valeurs et nos convictions
donc on est en capacité de vous proposer
une alternative une alternative forte
pour remettre effectivement le
département au club ses compétences
directeur de cabinet du maire de
montigny le bretonneux pendant 19 ans
avant d'en devenir lui même le premier
élu l'an dernier alors un merckaert
espère maintenant leur succéder au sein
de l'assemblée départementale
j'ai une connaissance des dossiers du
territoire aussi importante et des
personnes aussi des interlocuteurs des
différents partenaires et que dans le
cadre de ma fonction de maire et de ma
délégation à l'aménagement et
l'urbanisme à l'agglomération
ça me semblait judicieux de pouvoir
mettre cette expérience au profit du
département à 25e sur la liste
victorieuse aux municipales en 2014
avant de devenir maire en 2019 après la
démission de marie christine le tarnec à
guyancourt françois morton est
aujourd'hui bien installé dans sa
commune il veut fédérer les forces de
gauche dans leur ensemble nous avons
fait le choix et nous l'avons dit dès le
début que ne souhaitions pas avoir tous
les logo possibles et imaginables sur
nos affiches parce que nous sommes une
candidature citoyenne je ne veux pas
faire
j'adhère au parti socialiste alors que
ça n'est pas vrai claire ne veux pas
faire croire qu'elles adhèrent europe
ecologie les verts alors que ça n'est
pas vrai voilà c'est une réalité
c'est une candidature dans la sincérité
les choses sont très claires on rejette
pas les parties on en a besoin j'en suis
convaincu j'ai moi-même été adhérent
d'un parti politique par le passé je
fais le choix en ce moment de que ce ne
soit pas le cas
deux autres listes se présentent sur ce
canton de montigny le bretonneux le
binôme lrm de collines bécamel et
grégory pape et le binôme du
rassemblement national d'aurore du fayet
de la tour et de gaëtan bros